[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you hello good evening and welcome
to intelligence squared tonight's debate
is asking a very timely question is it
time to treat china as an adversary or a
partner we're very lucky tonight to have
four brilliant speakers to help us
decide but before we do we just wanted
to get a sense of where audience opinion
lies before we go into the debate so
whether you're an expert or you're just
a keen follower of the news could you
vote now
and tell us whether you're for or
against the motion
is it time to treat china as an
adversary so the motion is it's time to
treat china as an adversary so if you're
for that
please vote for if you think we should
be treating them as a partner please
vote against you can vote by going to
the link that you were sent in the email
when you booked or through the qr code
you can see just behind me if you're
struggling with a qr code we do have
ushers who should be walking around with
versions
to help you vote
if you're watching the live stream then
you should be able to vote using the
polls button on the right
if you click on that it should bring up
a series of options if you're not sure
at this stage and hopefully we might
swing your opinion one way or the other
by the end of the night but if you're
not sure please vote undecided
um we'll announce the the pre-vote
results after we've heard the speeches
now tonight's debate really couldn't be
more timely
we began the week with the leaders of
the world descending on glasgow some of
the broadcast media admittedly turned up
in edinburgh but you can't tell
americans anything
for what was the is the currently the
most important world gathering on
climate change in an attempt to lower
emissions
and and stop a terrible climate disaster
one nation was
notable by its absence not least because
it's the biggest emitter of carbon
dioxide in the world china and it's
the leader of the president xi the
leader of china failed to turn up the
american president joe biden called it a
big mistake and criticized china as a
nation that wants to show leadership on
big issues but somehow missed the
perfect opportunity to do it
also earlier this week the times an
excellent newspaper reported a meeting a
year ago between the foreign secretary
liz truss and the british ambassador for
china caroline wilson in which we are
told caroline wilson pointed out that in
order to increase trade and and have a
stronger partnership why can't the uk
treat china like the french
it's reported liz trust replied because
the french don't commit genocide
so
the rhetoric is ratcheting up
throw in tensions over hong kong fears
over taiwan
and a lot of frustration over china's
reluctance to aid the who's
investigation of of covert 19 and its
origins and there are an awful lot of
people at the moment you'll hear all
over the media and all over politics
across the west who are saying it's time
we treat china
as an adversary
whilst that's what the hawks will tell
you not everyone agrees
some people believe that cooperation
with china rather than confrontation is
the biggest and most important foreign
policy objective of the 21st century
we're not going to defeat china in the
way we defeated the ussr they'll tell
you
china will always exist
and the more hostile we are to it
the more its people are likely to be
hostile to us
unlike the ussr china isn't trying to
impose some global ideology on us so is
it time that we sort of understood and
sought to
manage china's interests and seek
partnership in as many ways as we
possibly can
which side is right
hopefully by the end of tonight you'll
have made up your mind
let's hear from our speakers and the
first speaker tonight to propose the
motion it's time to treat china like an
adversary is nathan law a remarkable
hong kong activist who's currently here
in exile
nathan during the umbrella movement in
2014 was one of the five representatives
who took part in the dialogue with the
hong kong government debating political
reform he set up his own political party
along with the now jailed activist
joshua wong and he was elected as the
youngest legislative councillor in hong
kong history in 2016. he's also just
written a book which you can buy at the
end of the event
called freedom how we lose it
and how we get it back ladies and
gentlemen nathan law
good evening ladies and gentlemen
when it was in 2017 i remember when i
was in hong kong jail
um
because of participation in peaceful
assembly i can still remember i was
treated like a number instead of a
citizen
still i was luckier than a lot of people
living in xinjiang human rights report
says that there are roughly 1.6 million
to three million vigors being locked in
modern day concentration camps they're
forcefully detained to unlearn their
culture and sometimes being tortured
there are variety reasons why they're
there sometimes they're just texting
their foreign relatives uh sometimes
they're learning weak language and
sometimes just being a teacher and
sometimes there are just no reasons
some of you are professors sitting there
being a professor and a wigan in china
could be dangerous
you come to tate a weaker scholar
promoting modern modern nation
moderation and reconciliation between
han chinese and uyghurs was sentenced to
life imprisonment in 2014
according to his friends and daughter he
is nowhere near an extremist or violence
agitator
some of you sitting down there i can see
a lot of young faces are student
activists joshua my best friend who is
now in jail who was just graduated from
university and the face of protest in
hong kong has been jailed for almost a
year the government accused him of
participating in a primary election so
the government basically says that if
you participate in a primary election in
hong kong in order to get the majority
in the legislature and in order to block
government's bill you are committing a
subversive action in order to overturn
the government under this definition
every single opposition candidate in the
uk will be jailed in hong kong the
regime has also prosecuted thousands of
protesters in 2019 some of them are
prosecuted just because they chanted
certain slogan some of them just because
they upheld certain political beliefs
ladies and gentlemen these are all done
under the chinese communist regime do
you really want to partner with them
tonight's motion is it's time to treat
china like an adversary not a partner
how do we understand partnership
partnership is about trust is about
respect and identify with each other's
value so the fundamental question you
should ask yourself before you phone
next is is china led by totalitarian
regime chinese communist party and the
dictator xi jinping are trusted and
respectful ally that shares similar
values with us
we're not talking about war
it's a narrative that is a slippery
slope and people who want to give a free
pass impunity to china uses because
we've got a lot of different mechanisms
to hold a human rights perpetrator
accountable other than going to war
it's not about cold war style
containment strategy we all understand
that the world is so complicated so
intertwined that it is impossible to
dissect into two worlds in two economic
systems
i think of identifying them as adversary
is to make a clear point
human rights and freedom are our central
beliefs we should try to stop a
totalitarian regime like the chinese
police party to get a free pass
china as an anniversary we could still
do business we can still interact
doing these things does not mean that we
have to see them as our partner we see
the chinese party as an adversary
because it intends to dismantle
democratic values by totalitarianism
attack democratic countries by short and
soft power and deprive their people from
their democratic rights
the very first priority of the chinese
community party is to retain empower at
all costs even though they have to roll
over their people with tanks
in china nowadays they are literally
more sophisticated and more
technologically advanced than the
overlapping states china has the largest
video surveillance system in the world
monitoring everything including your
water bill and how you walk
social creative system is in place in
some of the texting cities that it
control how people behave and also
persecute activists more by limiting the
opportunity to travel to take buses to
take plane they have complete control
over media every media outlet there are
party organs to monitor them and let
along the gigantic internet viable that
chinese people just cannot receive the
information from external world
propaganda surveillance disinformation
denial of truth and manipulation and
rewriting of the past these are textbook
characteristics of a totalitarian state
and china does it better than the one
depict in the book 1984.
in 2013 the dictatorship just assumed
power in issue document number nine it
describes promoting western
constitutional democracy promoting
universal values civil society and free
press etc
as
the seven not worthy problems that
destabilize the head germany of the
chinese communist party
these concepts have to be wiped off from
their system and from the public
discussion
these are just a part of the abundance
of proof that from the very beginning
they see the democratic system as
rivalry as adversary we didn't stop that
idea they did
if a country is so hostile to our
fundamental beliefs
do you feel like it would be possible
for them to be a good partner
and their attacks
is not only happening on domestic level
but on the global level they're
supporting different human rights
perpetrators regime around the world
including the myanmar military tutor who
just
murder people uh and who just conducted
a coup in february and also the north
korean leaders and also persecuting
exile activists extraterrestrially extra
legally and also economically
blackmailing countries that criticize
them like norway like australia and
lithuania
all these things combined the chinese
communist party becomes the largest
champion of dictators around the world
the latest human rights foundation
report says that it is a driving force
behind global assault on human rights
and even so even though there are still
people from opposition claim that china
is too important and too powerful to see
them as a rivalry of course i understand
the massiveness of china's economy but
that's the reason why we should start
resisting
start to decrease our reliance started
diversifying our economy we've been on
the wrong track to presume china would
liberalize themselves for over the past
decade which should be worrying but not
appeasing when you see such a regime
become so powerful
which at 10 years ago we should act
yesterday which act now
wishing that we should not wait until
tomorrow
before the democratic values erode so
deeply that there is no turning back
if democratic countries united
we've got more than half of the global
economy and that's enough to counter
beijing's threat in 2020 despite
beijing's economic coercion china
remains australia's largest trading
partner
overall trade between the two nations is
down just two percent
in value since china's
import bans
new markets were found for many
australian ports for example much of the
wine once that signed for china now
comes to the uk
standing up against a chinese communist
regime
is not a doomed day
and for some they will say that
well we must collaborate with china over
climate change issue i agree this is the
most fundamental most important issue
that we have to face in this era but i
really don't like the idea that we must
relinquish our critics to china's human
rights violation otherwise they won't do
nothing
it is basically not true
china themselves have strong incentive
to address the problem they have a lot
of heatwave float extreme radars we've
seen that on news
when we engaged them before we have
solar grounds to believe that they have
no intention to honor promises and
treaties from the experience in wto
south china sea dispute and from the
situation in hong kong
what we need is not empty words of
collaboration but developing concrete
means to measure and ensure the outcome
of it
we've seen so many atrocities conducted
by the regime alone
and tonight is our opportunity to say
enough is enough
china is not our partner
our totalitarian regime is not our power
it's not our partner and never will be
vote for human rights vote for
democratic values and support actions of
conscience
support iham to text joshua wong jimmy
lai lester shame edward learn
remember their names they should not be
forgotten
they are not numbers they are human
thank you so much
um now before we go on just apologies
like this is clearly a sign of the
digital age but i don't actually have a
pen to hit the water so i'm hitting it
with my mobile phone when you've got a
minute left so take that as a sign if i
start manically uh whacking a bottle
with a phone um i'm delighted now to
call up our first speaker to oppose the
motion tonight it she is shirley yu and
she's a director of the china african
initiative at the london school of
economics she's also a senior fellow at
the ash center of harvard kennedy school
and a frequent speaker on china's
political economy in particular china's
belton road initiative and its
geopolitical implications she's written
three books in chinese on china by
ambassadors and the rise of the renminbi
and the fall of the yen are saved
ladies and gentlemen welcome surely you
[Applause]
thank you intelligence squared
nathan where one people i feel natural
closeness with you
madam chair ladies and gentlemen
i have been waiting for the past 10
months to hear the biden
administration's clear strategy on china
and this is the best i've come to
understand
we must compete with china on some
collaborate on others and confront on
the rest i call this the biden
administration's piecemeal china policy
for anyone who appreciates the long
telegraph and the containment strategy
that brought victory to the cold war
we understand that their policies need
to be strategic comprehensive and
clearly articulated and today let me ask
you that's the us the leader of the free
world
sees china as an adversary or a partner
you may just tell me
it's puzzling
when the liberal global water was
established in the 20th century the
united states took up nearly 50 percent
of the global gdp now with that kind of
global scale the us could absolutely
build the global order according to its
own image today no longer
the us is about a quarter of the global
gdp china came close to about 80 percent
of the united states and china's
economic side is already bigger than
that of the eu combined
chinese economist justin evelyn asked
the rhetorical question when would the
united states concede to china's success
it would be when china's economy is
twice the size of the united states and
its per capita gdp at half of the united
states
and i agree that when china gets there
it'll be almost too late for the united
states to reverse courts
or history
the west should not treat china as an
adversary
reason one because the u.s is currently
suffering from imperial overreach just
as the uk did at the turn of the 20th
century the u.s is no longer exerting
the type of global leadership that are
essential to support and uphold global
liberal democratic values in july 2019
u.s congress passed the hong kong human
rights and the democracy act
there were rumors at the time that the
u.s was going to sanction chinese banks
by removing them from the international
swift system and had the u.s done that
the chinese banking system would have
just collapsed the u.s did not choose
the fatal option and instead u.s
congress sanctioned the lineup of hong
kong and chinese senior officials the
outcome
the only pain i think for carrie lam is
that she has to get reacquainted with
using cash
and at next week in beijing at the sixth
planum of the chinese communist party's
congress a new chinese leadership lineup
will be announced for the next decade
and with that the current legislative
lineup will be deemed obsolete so the
pain the u.s has imposed on china over
hong kong and other issues has been so
minuscule and that's important china on
other territorial ambitions in january a
coup happened in aung san tsuji's
government in myanmar the biden
administration waged the sanctions but
the
military junta is still running myanmar
if no protection of democracy
could be achieved in a small economy
such as myanmar
think about what the u.s can do to a
large economy
such as china
if that does not destroy the illusion of
how much the u.s is actually supporting
global democracy and human rights
movement i don't know
what else does
so nathan
the us's fragile support has helped
co-create hong kong's tragedy and maybe
soon in taiwan
the west should not treat china as an
adversary because a cold war can be
peaceful and competition can be great
the u.s and china have been in the de
facto cold war 2.0 for a couple of years
now china is now going out to the world
to build a global proletariat community
as mao zedong once claimed and it would
be wrong to conceive
today's global paradigm on an
ideological basis but cold war 1.0 was
ironically also named the long cheese
a bipolar global water is inherently
more stable than the unipolar world
bipolarity brings not only peace but
also severe competition centered on
technology so today china is arguably
the de facto global leader on telecom
infrastructure china will soon launch
the world's first major sovereign
digital currency that aims at revamping
the 20th century global monetary order
china's autonomous driving technology
the first widely adopted application on
ai is arguably a par with the united
states china owns 70 of the global solar
energy supply chain and most of it is
located in xinjiang china of the
top 10 wind turbines dollars in 2020
seven were chinese and in 2020 china
launched one third of the global
satellites
two millennia of global economic history
has taught us one thing that the world
has only begun to economically take off
on the back of the industrial revolution
so whoever owns the next global
technological frontier is going to own
the leadership of the 21st century now
competition is a great thing during cold
war of the 20th century u.s landed on
the moon we stopped that because
competition was over now in 2024
americans will be on the moon once again
and in the meantime china has just
launched the core cap shows
capsules of its own international space
station now when we have the world's two
largest powers
in the fierce competition eventually it
is the whole world that are going to be
the beneficiary with this level of
exacerbated technological diffusion
the world should not treat china as an
adversary because china is the bridge to
the 21st and the 22nd century
china's technological rights is not
isolated chinese bringing the developing
world with it with china's judicial
partnership rwanda a country that
suffered from genocide in 1998 has just
become one of the world's top five
fastest growing economies according to
the imf and in a cuban newspaper a
headline flashed that havana is going to
have 5g before miami not think about
this possibility what about nigeria
having 5g before the uk
it would be because of china because
china's rise means the rise of the
developing world africa by 2060 is going
to have the labor force equivalent to
both china and india's combined and it's
china supercharges into an aging society
china will be left with no option but to
deeply intertwine its industrial supply
chain with asean and increasingly with
africa china today single-handedly owns
twenty percent of africa's debt builds
one-third of africa's power
infrastructure china finances in various
degrees 46
ports across sub-sahara and africa and
china has built submarine infrastructure
to provide high-speed internet to the
continent now on the country we see
consistent u.s fdi outflow out of africa
if the west isolates china then how does
the west connect with the 21st century
global economic reality that is going to
be led by asia and the 22nd century
increasingly led by africa the last
point why the west should not treat
china as an adversary is because china
by definition will evolve over time
chinese history has shown
that it's extended over 20
major dynastic periods starting from
approximately two millennia bc and in
some of these dynastic periods of course
china was divided into five or ten
kingdoms at the same time the people's
republic of china
as you may say is the 21st major ruling
period of the chinese landmass and now
without a doubt
this won't be the last ruling polity in
china or the end of history for china
what has given the chinese communist
party the ruling legitimacy has been the
consistent rise of economic prosperity
the current plan is by 2035 china's per
capita gdp is going to hit 20 000 u.s
dollars putting china solidly in a high
income country status now if there were
a concept of social contract and by the
way there is not it would be
exchange of economic prosperity for
social stability but there is a danger
that the chinese government may not
consistently continue to produce that
economic prosperity so china will remain
a vulnerable power filled with many
domestic challenges and i would suggest
that the west let's just stay chill
for
by 2050 let's give china
the benefit of the time and let china
mature and i can guarantee you by 2050
the china that we will be dealing with
will be a very different china from the
one that we see today fukuyama once said
that human history must be seen not as a
succession of civilizations or
succession of economic accomplishments
and more importantly it must be seen
as a succession of different forms of
consciousness
we are
on a learning curve together thank you
thank you shirley and now our third
speaker tonight is another speaker for
the motion
for the motion it's time to treat china
as an adversary rather than a partner
and i'm really glad tonight to be able
to
introduce you to alan mendoza who is the
co-founder and executive director of the
henry jackson society the foreign policy
and national security think tank which
promotes freedom and liberty um allen is
also a columnist for the city am the
london's business newspaper and is a
frequent commentator for the bbc sky
bloomberg every every respectable
everyone wants a piece of alan so we're
delighted he could join us tonight
thank you
well thank you for that very warm uh
introduction and i want to start this
evening ladies and gentlemen by focusing
on the actual words in the motion itself
or the language of the motion because it
asks us whether we should be considering
china as a partner or an adversary and i
think those are important terms because
a real definition of being a partner is
not merely one of being engaged
neutrally with another personal entity
but the sense that you share something
much bigger with them a commonality
across various areas that you are
consciously working towards building
something better as a unit than you
could do separately think of a business
partner for example or even dare i say
see a few of those a romantic partner
even would you feel that those are
people who had your joint best interest
at heart of course you would would they
be people you respected for the way they
behaved absolutely would they be people
you trusted completely of course the
answer is yes now contrast that with the
behavior of an adversary that is someone
who you are invariably engaged in
competition with and i think actually
shirley pointed out all the areas of
competition which will drive us towards
landing on the moon again but there are
areas of competition nonetheless with a
country that is clearly an adversary
would you feel that such a country had
your best interest at heart of course
not do you think you would admire the
way they behaved not at all would you
trust them absolutely not
i think you can see where i'm going with
this because the plain fact is that when
you consider the reality of china today
in its regime it is clearly in the
adversary camp and not in the
partnership and i think it is important
to state as we said at the start
actually this is the chinese regime we
are talking about the communist party
of china not the chinese people many of
whom would agree that the state is
unthinkable to its interests and hates
them because the way it controls them if
only they had a chance to express
themselves because of course ladies and
gentlemen the reality is that in 2021
china is an oppressive police state and
a surveillance state now back at the old
cold war days it was a joke you would go
to a hotel in the soviet union if you're
foreign you'll turn up there'd be no
towels and you'll say stand in the
middle of the room talk to yourself
there are no towels in this room and
suddenly a flunky would appear at the
door few minutes later with towels that
was soviet style surveillance today in
china it is much more advanced than that
your your thoughts are monitored on the
internet your words are checked out in
social messaging apps everything is
monitored to make sure that you do not
divert from the party line and if you do
divert from that line you risk losing
benefits or you risk being taken away
you could even risk never be seen again
that is the nature of china today and
that is of course if you are part of the
majority han chinese population if you
happen to be one of those poor
unfortunate people who are a group the
chinese state wishes to subjugate like
the ouijas like the tibetans like the
falun gong your fate is much worse those
freedom fights in tibet risk constant
arrest and torture for their actions if
you're the falun gong you have to go
deep into private life to practice your
beliefs and of course if you're a ouija
you face a prospect of slavery in
concentration camps and worse acts of
genocide that we know have been taking
place in xinjiang province now i ask you
look at that for one second
think about it is that the behavior of a
partner you would like or is it the
behavior an adversary that you actually
face because those are not the values of
this country but they are the values of
china today
but perhaps you need more convincing so
let's take a look at cop 26 just in the
news of course efforts made
internationally by many countries to try
and counter the terrible threat of
climate change now
china is the world's biggest greenhouse
gas emitter and it is responsible for 25
percent of the world's total emissions
yet its president chose not to attend
the conference and instead gave a
million mouth statement that merely
restated current commitments of china
and china's national emissions plan is
widely regarded as not being anywhere
near enough to keep the global
temperature from rising above 1.5
degrees celsius and equally if you look
at what china has done in recent weeks
it is of course not signed up to the uh
methane emissions treaty that many would
like to join 80 countries did china
didn't and of course it's decided to
start firing up coal uh power stations
now why is it doing that because it
needs to it for its own economic
interest so here we are sitting in the
uk at glasgow trying to act in the
world's interest and china once again
acting in its own interests why because
it's an adversary not a partner partners
work together adversaries work in their
own interest in china once again has
demonstrated that but okay let's take
that aside let's try another arena let's
look at how china's neighbors and our
other friends in the region view that
country would that give us some
confidence about china's true intentions
unfortunately not
wherever you look in the east and south
china seas china generates only fear and
concern about its behavior whether it is
seizing or building islands in its
neighborhood in breach of the united
nations convention on the law of the sea
or sparring with countries like japan
south korea and the philippines china's
aggressive bullying behavior should give
us cause for concern about where our own
relationship might be headed
pity poor australia which was hit with a
barley and wine boycott for having the
temerity suggest that there should be a
proper investigation into the origins of
which even the world health organization
now says is impossible to conduct
because of the opposition of the chinese
regime to allowing us to understand what
really went on in the wuhan institute of
virology in those days before
coronavirus began to run riot around the
world
and spare a thought for taiwan a true
partner to this country
constantly menaced by the chinese
military and chinese diplomatic
maneuvers designed to threaten and cow
that country in submission for daring to
suggest it might be better off as an
independent nation rather than reunited
under the communist jack boot
partner or adversary our other friends
would say very much the latter and then
there is the ip theft and industrial
espionage that china engages on an
industrial scale
would you trust a country that stole
from you
because that is what china does to
countries who once saw themselves as
partners
the u.s independent and bipartisan
commission on the theft of american
intellectual property estimated that iep
theft cost the u.s between 225 and 600
billion dollars annually that's one
point three percent to three percent of
us gdp and in its report the ip
commission was clear where the blame lay
stating unequivocally that china is the
world's principal ip infringer
and in case you're feeling left out here
as a british audience sitting here in
london tonight in december 2018 the
national cyber security center announced
that a group of chinese hackers known as
apt-10 acted on behalf of the chinese
ministry of state security to carry out
a malicious cyber campaign targeting
intellectual property in the uk and its
environment note that body revealed that
the uk was a significant target of ap
10. perhaps this is why the british and
u.s governments have banned the
involvement of chinese companies like
huawei from involvement in critical
infrastructure projects because they
believe it is too great
a risk to have chinese involvement in
them hardly the behavior expected of a
country regards a partner much more that
of an adversary
i could go on i could cite the fact that
china recently engaged in threats
against british naval wrestles
excising the right of freedom of
navigation in international waters near
china or that china has placed sanctions
on british members of parliament former
colleagues of uh savints
who have dared to call out behavior
but i don't think i need to
because the plain fact is that many of
us in this room will feel that china's
doubts about china's intentions have
grown not diminished in recent years and
are likely to grow still further the
china of 2050 that was spoken of is out
of china more likely to be our friend or
our enemy i'm afraid the direction of
travel is clear and that is why i hope
you will listen to those voices that you
have said tonight what china is really
about and agree with this side of the
house that china today and even more
importantly china tomorrow is an
adversary and not a partner thank you
thank you alan
and i'm delighted now to announce our
final speaker tonight
sir vince cable mp for twickenham for
over 20 years leader of the liberal
democrats between 2017 and 2019 and he
was the secretary of state for business
innovation and skills in the coalition
government between 2010 and 2015 and the
president of the board of trade
vince has also written a number of books
including his latest which will be
available at the end of the event
tonight
called the chinese conundrum engagement
or conflict examining the long history
of china and the west
well ladies and gentlemen
well ladies and gentlemen i i agree with
the previous speaker the the debate
hinges on what we mean by partnership
uh and i want to start with with the
economic arguments and
repeat some of what cindy said earlier
that
if we go back half a century
we had some in china some of the
utter horrors of the modern world a
great leap forward the cultural
revolution
this was a country characterized as it
had been for a century with
famine
hunger poverty and chaos
but deng and his successors
converted china into a successful
capitalist
economy and in the process turn china
into what is now
the biggest economy in the world on some
measures
biggest trading partner in the world the
biggest recipient of foreign investment
and china is the future of the world
economy followed by india in due course
and it's self-indulgent to the point of
silliness
to believe that we can do any other than
seriously engage
with a country of this kind and i spent
five years in government trying to do
that and
we had good outcomes
we know we still have an integrated
steel industry the chinese firm bought
scanthorpe from tartar steel we
we will have a um electric vehicle
industry because the chinese company is
building one of the biggest battery
companies in the world in the northeast
of england
jaguar land rovers vast sales and
profits in china have helped that
company to expand the industry in the
west midlands
astrazeneca has provided our vaccine on
the back of
massive sales and profits in china
i'm based listening to university and
british university students expansion
has been financed by 125 000 chinese
students every year
coming and paying commercial fees
but that's a bit parochial if you look
at it from a global standpoint it was
actually the chinese along with gordon
brown and obama who
refloated the world economy after the
crash
and the banks collapsed
the chinese have consistently over four
decades used their vast holdings of
american dollars to keep the world
monetary system stable to prevent
currency wars
it wasn't the chinese it was the last
president of the united states and
probably the next one
who
systematically tried to sabotage the
world trading system on which the
prosperity of rich and poor countries
depends
and coincidentally right now
the chinese are amid this plethora of
economic announcements opening their
economy as they've been urged by
westerners to do
uh to the financial sector um biggest
banks in the world the black rocks and
jp morgan's right now i've been given
free range to go into china
set up institutions buy up shares for
western investors
um
but of course it's not all economics
we've we've heard about human rights and
china is
authoritarian extremely authoritarian
can be brutal there's no point trying to
conceive like i don't conceive it
but
we have to what we have to look at is
the balance
between on the one hand there are
enormous advances in economic and social
rights
and the very very lamentable record in
human rights and in fact
china ranks above only saudi arabia in
the freedom house classification of
human rights abuses saudi of course
being one of our close partners
economically and militarily
but but it is a you know the new arts
abusers of course there's no doubt about
that but there's one fact to remember
before the covid restrictions came in
every year
130 million chinese
left china to work to study to shop
do their tourism
at the end of it
they went back freely
and it's worthwhile remembering that the
henry jackson institute was set up in
the name of an american senator
who campaigned against the soviet union
because they wouldn't let people out
the chinese do let people out they go
and they come back
and they consent to do so so this is an
authoritarian regime but of a particular
kind
that commands the support
of a large number of its own people
but the concern that's been expressed on
the panel is it's
the way it looks to the rest of the
world
and you in a caricatured form you often
say you know china's
militaristic it's aggressive
it's trying to conquer the world
it's worth noting the chinese spend
two percent of the national product on
defense the same as we do
nato average
the americans
and i'm a great fan of the united states
have 200 military bases around the world
the chinese have
two
they are
little known fact the largest
contributor to united nations
peacekeeping
so it's you know there is a lot of
aggressive language
but the reality is a bit different
and president g set out as stall very
clearly 10 years ago when he became
president he said look
china is like this we
we don't export terrorism
we're not sending you hungry refugees
we don't mess with you
don't mess with us
okay
it's crude
but it's a very clear statement of a
chinese approach to
the rest of the world which is
non-interference
and territorial integrity which is
accounts for the position they take on
xinjiang and hong kong and taiwan
and it has a lot of support in the rest
of the world you know we feel
there's also moral indignation in the uk
about china but
when
the american administration the trump
administration alleged for the first
time
about the abuse of muslims in xinjiang
and leading to extermination on some
claims
and undoubtedly is human rights abuse
every single
islamic majority country in the world of
any substance
including the democratically elected
indonesian malaysia bangladesh pakistan
nigeria supported the chinese position
why would they do that
but
the argument is not about fundamentally
about
non-interference it is about partnership
to solve common problems and just my
final comment is this
that we we have a whole series of
international public goods common
headaches
global warming is one pandemics is
another
nuclear proliferation is probably the
most serious of all
now
without china we cannot begin to solve
these problems
you know our existence depends on having
a partnership with them
and you can argue about whether the
chinese or the americans made the
biggest lack of contribution to the
climate talk but actually
they have to work together and they have
to cooperate
otherwise these problems will never be
solved
so that's why i believe we have to form
a partnership
a new cold war
doesn't help anybody thank you
thank you vince and thanks to all of our
speakers tonight um we are about to open
the debate up to the audience so do feel
free to send in your questions if you're
watching the live stream you can do that
by clicking on the q and a button
do type in your question if you want to
add your name and where you're tuning in
from it's always nice to know if you're
in the room in a slightly sort of um
post-covered gesture we want you to
rather than putting your hands up would
you mind just coming and queuing behind
one of the mics here we'll form an
orderly queue we'll try to get through
as many questions as possible
before we do that though i just want to
announce the results of the pre-vote
that we did at the start of the session
and i looks very much at the start of
tonight's event that the fall
for the motion so um people do think we
should be treating china as an adversary
by 53
against people for partnership was 22
percent
undecided 25 so there's still an
opportunity there for you um let's see
how we get let's see where we get to by
the end of the night um we're already
getting a cue which is great do keep
coming if if you have any questions at
all um but could we begin
with you thank you very much um i'd just
like i'd like to ask shirley and vince
just one question what would each of you
what's the single thing you'd want china
to change
to be easier to partner with
maybe i'll go first
china has developed enormous hard power
needless to say both economic power but
also military power but china has not
yet matured with its uh soft power the
west that has tremendous amount of self
power and so if china needs to learn one
thing and grow maturely on the global
stage it would be that china needs to
learn
and develop is soft power i'll give you
one quick example in the recent postcode
19 world the china continues to talk
about win-win solutions when we talked
about the relieving african debt china
said well we prefer to resort to african
debt issues on a bilateral level on a
win-win basis now condoleezza rice
former u.s secretary of state said once
if china wants to be the global global
leader let it because unless china
becomes one china would not understand
the sacrifices it takes to be a global
leader in china needless to say as if
china does aspire to take on the global
leadership responsibility then china
needs to understand the world is no
longer about win-win it is about lose
win because it takes true leadership to
lose in order for the rest of the world
to win
finns
well it's a slightly flippant answer but
i i would say probably the most
important thing they need at the moment
is good public relations advice
they got
terribly terrible at presenting
themselves actually
there is a very good defense
well i've written a book you can form
your judgments as to whether what rule
it performs but you know actually
you know there are
the little factoid i mentioned about
participating in u.n peacekeeping
uh the fact that their their military
defense is very very limited except in
some highly specialized high-tech areas
uh they've they've started using this
rather foolishly in my view this wolf
warrior communication system which none
of us understand it's it's a peculiar
use of language and it's very
off-putting and gives the impression
that chinese are highly aggressive which
is actually not the case
i'm actually going to extend that
question to this side too is there what
would need to change in china for you to
think they'd be a good partner now
it's government um i mean basically
vince has given you this wonderful
impression that china is this benign
why certain majority muslim nations
didn't vote on the ouija issue because
china has literally bought them with
billions of dollars of economic
development aid in the belt and road
initiative
[Applause]
that government is a source of problems
and until china is not a communist state
it cannot be a partner
nathan is there one thing is it is it
human rights is it sort of
more protection for the citizens of hong
kong what is the one thing that would
make it china a much easier partner well
definitely the government i think i
think that's the perfect answer
if we look at what the opposition has
been saying that they're saying that
they're economically superior so that we
have to see them as partners but they
forgot one thing is when bad people when
the malign force have more power they're
actually doing more damage to the world
and that's why we should start thinking
we should start thinking about like what
are their systems and what they're using
the power with their economic uh of
power in the world and how we can hold
them accountable when they do such a lot
of human rights violation around the
world and i think this is exactly the
problems that we should ask
um i'm going to ask a question from the
left before i do if is there any women
who'd like to ask questions please do
come forward too
don't do don't feel you
you can't
um i would like to ask
the opinion of each of the panel
why each of them feels
why there are so few chinese spaces here
this evening
it's a very interesting question i think
we'll start with nathan
i'm sorry so few chinese
chinese faces here
this evening
so i've had um a lot of talks in
universities and there were a lot of
times that chinese students approached
me and to talk to me after the talk
because they were worried that when they
are present and they are being spotted
and they are being turned to the embassy
or anything that they could get in
trouble
um
um surveins just said that um there are
lots of chinese people coming out and
coming back but they but we
we just have to remember that these
people even though they're overseas
they're continuously being monitored
they are having a lot of connections in
their
country whenever they create troubles
there will be calls to their families
their family store will be knocked and
there will be uh
police or any sort of these um thing to
come up and to threaten them so this is
a concrete worries for them even though
they're outside of the country
vince is that
is that some yes well i teach quite
large numbers of chinese students have
the same institution as cindy they're
very forthcoming they speak freely ask
intelligent questions i guess the reason
they're not here we actually have a very
small
chinese minority in the uk
probably if we had a more liberal
approach to immigration we would see
more of them
if i made you sad it could also be
because of kobe 19 restrictions i almost
didn't make it tonight uh traveling from
the united states back to the uk but
also there is certainly a trend of human
capital decoupling between china and the
western world there's no doubt about it
shirley do you worry as nathan said that
people would be afraid to come to a
forum like this to be seen oh i'm sure
many will be afraid of course i teach at
harvard kennedy school and of course you
know that the past year we have to do uh
lecturing online and so i was told just
as a general a cautionary note that
don't ever assume that the zoom will not
be
off the record it's just on the record
and what that means is that a lot of the
chinese students who are participating
in political debates at universities
back at home in china they may be
cautious about what they speak
is that alarming is that something
makes it harder to for us to work as
partners giving it such a different
culture
it's the reality
allen anything to add well i think
shirley is a sleeper for the proposition
here tonight and she's she's telling you
exactly why the chinese regime is such a
disaster and why we can't possibly be a
partner with them if even chinese
students dare and speak in public but it
is look the surveillance issue is a real
one it's very important china monitors
people abroad as well as at home there's
a case in the us right now where the u.s
authorities have uh you know have
accused china of surveilling a
dissidence in the u.s that's the reality
this is not the behavioral partner
however alan may i just come back just
to defend my position we have to learn
from harvard something i just i was at
harvard two weeks ago and i was so happy
to see many chinese faces there can you
imagine an enormous amount of pressure
for the elite universities in the united
states today to accept the chinese
students to come to the u.s to debate
about these fundamental political issues
we have to give them a lot of credits to
have the guts to continue to welcome
chinese students and we have to welcome
and engage with china there is no other
option than that
we will come to you in just a moment but
actually because i called for them i
sort of feel like we should just give
one of the women a chance first
thank you
hi um thank you for this um so my
question is first of all i was very
surprised by the results i find them
very emotional i would i would
personally propose partnership but my
question is we've talked a lot about the
u.s but what's your view on the european
union and also on a in a post-brexit era
what's the view on how the uk and eu
should be working on defining a
partnership with china because i think
post-trump we're also alone in this so
i'd love to understand for a good
partnership there needs to be you know
two sides and the u.s has mentioned a
fair bit but really love to understand
more about eu
uk and and how we're going to how we're
going to get there together well vince
we'll start with you
um what should well yes i think i think
particularly brexit context is a very
good one i mean i think if britain
wanted to
be in the comfortable position of always
dealing with countries with the same
values and same standards we should have
stayed in the european union but we
didn't and we're now a
global britain which means we have to
engage with the world as it actually is
outside and
we we tend to forget i mean there's a
lot of you know pontificating about
china but
some of britain's closest economic and
defense
relationships are with countries like
saudi arabia and the gulf states
egypt turkey
which have human rights records which in
some cases are as bad or worse than with
china but that's the world we have to
deal with uh and
you know i'm afraid just shutting it out
i mean just just a quick rejoinder to an
early point people that the indignant
that the chinese are lending money to
africa
why are they lending money to africa
because we have walked away right
britain's cut its aid program western
multinationals have pulled out
there's a vacuum the chinese have
advanced capital for development because
nobody else will
and then we lecture the chinese and say
they're behaving badly i mean there's
extraordinary self-righteousness here
which is totally unacceptable
alan i'm going to go to you um i mean
did you accept vince's point in the
post-brexit world we now have to we now
have to take partnerships wherever we
can get them
no one is saying that we shouldn't
engage with china i mean no one on this
side would say boycott china go towards
that's not what we're saying we're
saying be alive as to the reality of who
you are dealing with you know and vince
mentioned certain regimes who we aren't
particularly uh proud of our i think our
human rights uh uh you know records yet
we still deal with them the reality is
that we know what those regimes are all
about we know and with their limits as a
result of how closely we do act with
them and that's really where the eu's
going to have to go with china as well
it's going to obviously have to trade
with china no one suggests that's not a
good thing however must it trade in
china in key strategic industries where
national security of various countries
are engaged with you know you discover
that china actually ends up with a
monopoly or at least um a large
proportion of some of the most key
components to uh a nation security
that's not a sensible place to be once
you've identified it's not really a true
partner and adversary okay trade with it
trade with it in certain goods but let's
not pretend that we can avoid where that
country's at real likely interests are
they won't be aligned with us we
therefore need to protect ourselves so
it's a realistic engagement it's
understanding china's a big country we
want to be part of it but we must make
sure we are not so intertwined that
should there be a crisis we are not held
hostage to what the chinese do because
we've seen it so many times before the
australian case is just one example of
how china punishes countries who don't
agree with it and that's a bad news for
everyone in that sense
so can i just quickly respond to this
national security issue because the
issue of huawei and 5g was raised
earlier and i happened to deal with this
in government over a five-year period
and it was repeatedly reassured by the
intelligence community who should know
that
our dealings were totally safe
and the same judgment was followed by
theresa may when she succeeded the
government i was in
and the reason we have disengaged from
china and huawei and 5g has got nothing
to do with british national security
it's because we were told by the
americans that we had to
and the germans who took a view in their
national interest
kept with 5g and as if britain had we
would now be at the forefront of
countries using the most advanced
telecommunications technology and we're
not no i have to come back i'm sorry i
have to come back on that because that's
that's a point of view however the other
point of view is quite clearly that
having a company which has um which
would be of course uh
responsible to the chinese government at
any moment it wanted data and control of
that company
being part of your communications
network is a disaster for this country
we've seen examples where chinese
companies have been told what to do by
the chinese state that's not a place for
any country which has serious national
security issues to allow such a company
to control its 5g network and that's why
britain did not do it nothing to do with
american pressure in that
regard so am i taking from here that the
eu the uk don't have a strategy to
engage because it seems
uh
should i jump in this question yeah well
i think if we we're talking partnership
as if we're seeing china that no
problems in china and there are no
problems in the way that we engage with
them for the best tech case and that's
something that i don't agree with
we have to engage with it but we have to
see how they
abuse that kind of like trading
relationship and their power over the
world to conduct all sorts of uh bad
behaviors including they're using forced
labor to export uh
the solar panel they're using forced
labor to do work on xinjiang cotton
they're doing a lot of economic uh
blackmailing to countries like norway
when they well
after they uh the no the nobel peace uh
prize was awarded to lucha ball they
blocked the trade even though it was not
about the government but the institute
but the chinese government still do so
still using their belgians behavior in
order to silence the other countries if
you look at the case of the australia
the propaganda machine is describing
australia as the gum under the shoes and
that's the reason why we have to work on
defining that as adversary in order to
work on these problems until we've got a
respectable and we've got a
relationship that both sides agree on
and and this is the result why we are
not talking about partnership now but we
should have made some change
thank you
um we will come back to some of the
questions here i just wanted to ask a
quick one from um some of our online
audience got a question that's coming
saying how can we make china accountable
if another pandemic emerges from the
country um
shirley do you want to take that
oh
i remember uh when kobe 19 first broke
out um
at the uh in spring of 2020 we had a
lecture at the llc where we had a
conversation with
larry summers from harvard kennedy
school
larry was amazing and he said
look
this sort of pandemic
the world has to be prepared for it to
come back once every decade or so and
that is fundamentally because of rapid
urbanization all across the developing
world and particularly in asia pacific
and if you look at asean economies they
are rising very quickly indonesia i
think the gdp growth is like five and a
half percent and so with rapid
urbanization there is a higher need of
uh protein consumption and the human and
animal interactions are going to become
more intense it may not break out in
china it might break out in another
developing country but i think the world
would have to be prepared that there
will be more these type of virus that
will eventually spread into a global
pandemic and what that calls for
are pre-active proactive responses you
see the global government are they tend
to be reactive when emergency happens
and i should say that i see many masks
in this room and we are still
suffering from the aftermath of covet 19
and
that really caused for multilateral
organizations and the national
governments to really set up proactive
responses in order to protect the
citizens livelihood when the next one
hits
and that china is included as well
should there be more accountability
though should they should they be doing
more to to enable the current
investigation into into the origins and
how do we how do we trust them to be
more open next time
it's interesting because uh
president biden has announced a 90 days
i believe independent investigation of
the origins of covet 19 and i believe
that result was released sometime at the
beginning of september and then that was
the u.n general assembly where president
biden president xi jinping were both
present via video
it's just almost as if this whole covet
investigation disappeared from the
universe no one seemed to talk about it
and today we seem to have gone past that
era of accusing one another but i think
as rational citizens what we really
ought to do is not to say
that
you know the effect of course we need to
continue to investigate because that
helps us to prevent the next pandemic
from happening but we really ought to
hold our own governments and these
global multilateral organizations
accountable
vince was there anything you wanted to
add how do we make china accountable the
next time there's a pandemic
sorry the question was how can we make
china accountable if another pandemic
emerges from china
well as far as the last pandemic is
concerned the the biden administration
just as
you know just set up an investigation
into it and established that
an accidental leak was perfectly
plausible but the most
likely outcome almost certainly was that
it was zootonic transmission
it was an unfortunate accident
the chinese did spend two weeks covering
up what was going on which was highly
reprehensible but they then cooperated
fully in
the
getting to the dna of the of the
molecule and cooperating in solving this
problem and as you know from the recent
crackdowns last few weeks they're now
taking this disease a lot more seriously
than we are
so yeah i mean we have no alternative
but to cooperate i mean this is a it's
like climate change like um nuclear
proliferation these are common problems
the chinese accepts that their party to
it they're
unlike some administrations they're
guided by science
they do serious research
and
one little detail that was forgotten in
all the arguments about wuhan was that
the the wan institute where this leak
may have occurred may have occurred
was a joint project with the united
states
which mr fauci who was the
head of
public medicine in the united states was
overseeing
so if there was a if there was a failure
it was it was shared it wasn't unique to
the chinese
so
responsibility is widely spared here
let's not just go around pointing
fingers you've waited a while
do you step hi um so my name is rafi and
i'm here from city of london school
today and thank you very much it's been
really fascinating fascinating debate so
far um i wanted to pick up on something
shirley mentioned in your speech said at
the very beginning um about you use the
imperial overreach to refer to the usa
and in doing so you draw a parallel
between the us at the moment and britain
at the turn of the century now the thing
is um between the the sort of changeover
of global domination between britain and
america is that these two countries
shared fundamentally a similar view of
the world and as you know the
proposition defined partnership so well
you know britain and the uk are very
close partners so
my question is that the thing is
nowadays is that china as again the
proposition outline is a country that
should have very different values to us
and i think that you know the western
society that we have created is
something we should be proud of you know
the free society we've created is a
moral achievement and we shouldn't
forget that and you know it's it's
something we should be proud of i the
question is actually opposed to the
proposition because i agree we should
treat china as an adversary but when
we're seeing political division and
countries turning inwards looking at
ourselves you know trump won on a
campaign of america first you know how
can the west regain its sense of unity
to properly treat china as an adversary
as it should
alan do you want to take well actually i
think
firstly good to see a a citizen that's
marvelous to have you here with us um
being an old citizen myself but leave
that for one second
let's look at what you just said about
you know our own divisions what's
fascinating is that say in the us today
which perhaps the most divided if you
like of our political societies what is
the one issue the sole issue on which
there is a genuine bipartisan consensus
guess what it's china it's fascinating
actually the democrats and republicans
both seen this issue as one which is the
biggest uh threat to global sort of
stability going forwards and together
they have senators congressmen even you
know the presidents have both accepted
that china is that threat so i think
this tells you something significant it
means that even with our own divisions
in
uh in our current contemporary political
alliance the same by the way is true
here if you look at the labour front
bench you'll see lots of criticism of
china tory front bench the same um you
end up with a consensus on this one
issue and that should tell you that
people have woken up to the reality of
what china is they're convinced they
have to do something about it it doesn't
matter what party you're from action
needs to be taken now we are almost
running out of time but i just want to
try and get a couple of very quick
questions in so um do you want to ask
yourself uh yeah so hi uh thanks for the
debate so far so uh
i'd like to ask uh the pastor i think
the opposition opposition suggested that
the past of china suggest they would
eventually change and become more
democratic but surely we've tried for
like a golden decade we had xi jinping
come and meet with the queen etc and
including under the coalition and
there's been no change but just an
increase in hostility in taiwan threats
against australia hong kong and
terrorism and so genocide in xinjiang
what makes you think this time
or any time in the future will be
different so that's a quick one for
vince i think given that you were a
member of the colonies hearing these
questions um so uh as a member of the
coalition during that period with david
cameron and george osborne where china
was being welcomed in
um there were state visits
the doors were very much open to a
partnership
we don't seem to have made very much
progress on stopping uh genocide or on
sort of building up a relationship that
sort of functions i think that's
a quick
summary of the acoustics
um so during your time in the coalition
when david cameron and george osborne
were opening the doors to china it
doesn't seem to have made much
difference in our ability to change
chinese behavior or influence them in
terms of the problems of the uyghurs or
climate change well we we weren't trying
to
tell them how to run their own country
we were trying to conduct business with
them in a practical and equitable way
and i gave some examples as how this has
worked out productively but as it
happens
um i was in meetings with um
actually one meeting with the president
of china who jintao proceeded to
and the issue of tibet was raised and it
was raised in a proper and respectful
way and we notified them that this was a
problem that some people in britain were
concerned about
and they responded um
and providing they were not sort of
we were trying to ambush them or
humiliate them they're perfectly capable
of engaging with these issues i had a
very long
conversation um and having our
conversation with a man who's now in the
politburo
and will i think probably be the next
one of the premiers
um about human rights in the labor force
because you know i was responsible here
for you know minimum wage and all that
and i made the point to them that um you
know you're a socialist country so
supposedly um but there aren't very many
labor rights
and i'm in a wicked capitalist country
and we have minimum wages and protection
of trade unions and so on and
it didn't um you know throw up his hands
i refuse to discuss it we had a
perfectly sensible
discussion based on the fact that you
know china is evolving
many of the things i was discussing with
them are now being implemented in china
as part of their so-called common
prosperity move
they actually asked me to send
literature from the uk on how we were
dealing with minimum wage enforcement
and my experience of dealing with the
top chinese on issues of this kind
is that providing we're not presenting
ourselves as a sort of patronizing
westerners lecturing them on how to run
their country but treat them as a great
power and equals and with respect you
can have a perfectly sensible discussion
about where we go
you know there is an issue about respect
and about face which we have to
understand if you're dealing with china
but it can be done and we did it
uh very quickly we are completely out of
time but i just want to get one more
question i'm so sorry to everybody else
i get this makes me a really brave
chinese by the definition
so um one question very simple one so
like i can see the argument say that oh
because they don't share our same belief
or value a liberal democratic society
but they really want to see china as a
liberal democratic society to rewarding
silence and donald trump do we want to
see another ift in
deutschland and another le pen in france
let let me remind you china is running
very high on nationalism people are
populistic and they will elect leaders
to have i mean a strong leader
that might be stronger in terms of
nationalistic
views
than xi jinping right now
so um i guess that's the question for
both sides thank you well i'll start
with alan you you called for an end of
this government do you do you think
you've
asked for you know better the devil you
know no definitely not when that devil
happens to be a genocidal authoritarian
regime that enslaves hundreds of
millions of course not look the reality
is china had a great moment of democracy
potential in 1989 and what happened the
tanks literally crushed the democracy
protesters they literally killed them
okay that's the reality of it and since
that time the chinese communist party
has been ruthless in its maintenance of
power and its desire to control its
people and it's only getting worse not
better because the internet age and the
surveillance afforded makes china an
even more susceptible country to
surveillance by this regime and that's
your real problem you've got a state an
authoritarian state that's getting more
authoritarian not less and more
dangerous as a result
can i just add something really quickly
that's actually a really profound
question i just had this
conversation with a harvard professor
recently about vladimir putin in russia
and so the idea is that what the whole
uh post the cold war era people have
been hoping for a liberal russia
and then we got putin but his conclusion
is that we should be happy because in 10
years time
the person presiding over russia might
be even more
authoritarian than putin and then in 10
years time we're going to be so happy to
say oh my god that was the golden arrow
when we had putin so it's really
interesting i think the west is totally
unprepared today about
what's going to happen to china next
because there is a clear directional
shift during xi jinping era particularly
this year
on the cusp of the second century of the
chinese communist party that now there
is a strong sense of re-nationalization
china is definitely turning towards the
left but
who will be the successor and that
potential successor one day
might be even more on the left to xi
jinping and then
how does the west respond and so i think
we really are in a steep learning curve
and we ought to put in a lot of
realistic thinking about how to
realistically deal with china that is
possibly going to increasingly become
more prosperous but we are uncertain if
china will increasingly become more
liberal or not
just very briefly yeah just one word um
in order to verify your statement we
should have an election in china if they
are so popular by the time you and i can
vote and we will see the result of it
we've just got time now i'm so sorry
we've just got time to to move to the
closing statements i'm going to invite
vince first to just in a minute sum up
your side of the argument
well i i just in the two minutes i have
perhaps just
rehearsed
what i said at the
at the end of my my original comments
which is to try to focus
on those issues where we have common
threats and the need to build
partnerships to deal with them i mean
the whole week has been filled with
cop and
climate change and rightly it's an
existential problem
and there's a lot of finger pointing
you know the chinese are the biggest
emitters well actually in cumulative
terms there certainly aren't but anyway
regardless of
who is to blame
um there are many things that
you know the americans are doing
positively and others that they fail to
do on coal the chinese have actually
made a commitment and are now
implementing carbon pricing which has
proved too difficult in the west
particularly the states
they have banned
the export of co-generation power
stations
they have got the biggest
renewable power sector in the world and
they're putting it to use
but
if we're operating in a cold war
environment
in which there is no cooperation and
china is treated as a threat
and we're obsessed for example by you
know the intellectual property around
solar power rather than actually how you
share it
then this problem is not going to be
solved and it is a horrendous issue i'm
much personally much more concerned
about another problem which is nuclear
proliferation
we have issues of north korea iran
pakistan and the taliban
the chinese as it happens have
an entree to those governments which we
don't have
they could if they were minded and we
worked with them
act
in a restraining and helpful way or they
could make mischief we don't know
but it is in everybody's interest that
we actually
do work with them
and the rules of the world international
economic system that has made this
country and the rest of the world
prosperous in the last 70 years
is in serious peril
you know the world trade system the
monetary system it needs stable
governments the americans led it for
this time and they've generally led it
pretty well until trump
but we've now got two two economic
superpowers
and they're going to have to share
responsibility and the chinese are going
to have to be given equal status
and they will do it in their own way
with chinese characteristics but we need
them as partners there is no other way
that we can deal with these problems
without them
thank you
just in a minute absolutely right two
questions for you the first question is
do you deep down think about it
carefully do you feel more worried about
china internationally and domestically
than you did five years ago today i
think deep down all of us somewhere feel
that the answer will likely be yes to
that
and if that is the case you don't that's
very interesting i'd love to know later
why
um after all the bullying the harassment
the international threats the breaking
of international law the economic
exploitation the genocide after all of
that okay we can talk about it we can
talk about it now the second question
whether you answered yes or no to the
first given the direction of travel
think about five ten years time do you
think china is going to be more or less
of a threat internationally and
domestically than before and the answer
indisputably on this side of the house
is yes it will be and if you do believe
that then you surely have the obligation
to think about this carefully and go
that means there's an adversary and not
a partner adversity doesn't mean you
don't you cut off contact with it you've
still got to do engage and you've still
got to do things but be realistic about
where that country is heading and it is
not to a good destination
thanks alan just in a minute shirley
your case alan is a great campaigner but
let me appeal to some reason here
in the peloponnesian war ccd said the
norm of the state is that the strong do
what they can and the weak suffer what
they must 600 years ago world economic
gravity has shifted from the eurasian
continent or the inner crescent of the
world to the other crescent to the
atlantic region and now we are starting
to see the world's economic gravity
shifting back to the eurasian continent
but for that few centuries
we have had the liberal democratic
values that have essentially defined the
world and we have been living in a cozy
pax american world for the past seven
plus decades pakistan americana and pax
britannica were amazing golden eras of
our world history but they are not the
global norm in the post-pax american
world
before the us and china definitively win
that in this global economic race until
we see a definitive winner the world is
going to be fundamentally dominated by
hopsin values that is international
relations will be once again governed by
anarchy and the power in security and in
this hopsin world international
relations national interest matters and
balance of power matters
nathan final word
in 1969 after the tamil massacre a lot
of the foreign countries indeed input a
lot of boycotts in hong kong in china
and have albums about goals and a lot of
different measures uk was among one of
them who
were the very first to ease a
relationship to warm the relationship in
the year 2001 china joined wto
in the year 2008 they had the olympic
but then i was a proud chinese i cheered
whenever chinese got the gold medal
everyone in the world cheered for
china's achievement
in the year 20 2014 2015 the uk
government coined the term of golden era
it really means that uh the uk
government back then wanted to have a
warm and nice relationship with the
chinese government but look at decades
of engagement what we have left
are millions of people living in modern
day concentration camp
forced labour's hong kong protest has
been cracked thousands of my friends in
jail
and china when xi jinping talks about
win-win situation it means that china
wins twice
they're dominating
world's economy but also exporting their
authoritarianism and we've got improv
evidence of it so when we talk about
partners when we call about adversary
we're not partnering with someone who
has the power
has the economic superiority because
they could use those things to do bad
things
we are partnering with like-minded
allies to promote our mutual beliefs to
promote our democratic values because we
believe in inner dignity freedom and
democracy and that is why we have to see
it as an adversary that's why we have to
make it strict that we're doing it for
global democracy and for future
generations and for the people who still
felt could still speak freely and who
could still live from fear thank you
i'd like to thank all four of our
speakers tonight for making their cases
so powerfully
the talking on this side of the room is
now over it's time for the audience to
decide so please do now submit your
final vote
for or against the motion it's time to
treat china as an adversary
not a partner
you can vote using the same link you
used earlier for the pre-vote so either
the link you received in the email or
the qr code behind us if you're in the
room if you're watching via the live
stream it's the little poll button on
the right of the screen please do vote
for or against the motion if you're
still not sure please do vote undecided
we'll bring you those results any minute
now just a quick reminder before we do
though where we began
at the start of this event before anyone
had heard the speakers 53 of the
audience was for the motion was for
treating china as an adversary 22
percent were for treating china as a
partner and 25 percent were undecided so
it'll be interesting to see where we get
to um in the meantime if you would like
to tweet about tonight please do using
the hashtag iq2
if you want to continue the debate so
apologies for anyone who didn't get
their question in do carry on on twitter
and we'll
we'll all between us try to answer if we
can but keep it keep keep the argument
going um
we should have the results for you any
minute now um before we do though i just
wanted to thank our speakers again
tonight so nathan law
alan mendoza shirley you and vince cable
thank you very much
we haven't quite got the results yet
this is sort of the moment where the
countdown clock is ticking
the tension is rising um we should know
any second oh here we are so the post
results
are a triumph for
the motion 69
of the audience here for treating china
as an adversary
23
for treating china as a partner and only
eight percent now are undecided so thank
you all very much for voting and for
contributing and for sending in your
questions wherever you were